投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀,
現在是臺北時間2026年9月29號禮拜二,
早上8點31分,
大家早安,
我是劉廷浩,
不過在這邊時間應該是,
我也以那時間大概2點半吧,
人還在外地,
不過今天來跟投資朋友做一些指標來觀察一下美國股市臺北股市目前的概況,
畢竟10年期美債殖利率這一次已經突破5.2%了,
那這一次債券市場美國股市到底會否因此而受到顯著的影響呢?
我們如果細看這一波
其實十年期公債殖利率上升的速度非常之快
在過去一週又在短短快速的做跳升
道瓊指數收跌了347點
標普白指數收跌0.7%
納斯達克指數收跌0.92%
費辦指數重挫了1.6%
那麼在禮拜一美國股市的下挫以後
我們要如何來看待對於臺股的影響呢
畢竟現在禮拜三就要公佈
個人消費支出PCE的數據
以及禮拜五9月份的非農就業數據報告
那在這一次的數據當中就很重要了
因為任何的風吹草動
都有可能把債券市場持續的往下拉
那麼到底債券市場的沉壓
5.1%不影響5.2%
那有一天美債變成5.5%變成6%
難道對於股票市場都不會有任何的影響嗎
今天來跟投資朋友多做一些觀察
其實如果我們細看在整個2026年
今年的全球資產
哇 已經快要接近一半進入到負報酬了
雖然美國股市還是非常漂亮
尤其商品價格是以45.9%報酬率排行第一名
那主要還是受到能源和原物料價格上漲的帶動
所造成的影響
美國科技股的部分依舊強勢
納斯達克100指數是上漲21.6%
美國價值股是21%
可轉債是15.9%
小型股15.3%
大型股4%
那麼新市場的部分和已開發市場
分別上漲12%和11%
可是真正下跌的資產我們就看到了
債券市場現在是幾乎是一個慘次
尤其這一次十年期公債之利率
上升幅度這麼快的情況底下
市場幾乎沒有太多的接盤意願
美國整體債券今年平均下跌2.1%
投資等級債的部分下跌3.4%
長天期美債TLT下跌了6.2%
這是變成今年表現最差的資產
今年表現最差的資產居然換人當了
往年幾乎都是比特幣
現在變成了長天期美債
那麼黃金本來在2025年大漲了63%
今年看起來又是小跌0.7%
在過去一週又開始重挫
其實最慘的還是長天期國債了
這一次我們看到月線價格
跌到大概80.7塊左右的長期低點
目前已經來到79塊
放下掛牌以來的最低
如果從成交量的分佈來做觀察
85塊到90塊
因為這一波其實盤整了一段時間
上方是有非常龐大的套牢賣壓
意味著未來即便價格反彈
都要知道從心理位階來看
雖然很多人可能是持有職債
所以基本上也沒有太大的價格壓力
他就是持有到期
可是從價格層面來看
也會遇到不少的賣壓
黃金價格更是如此
黃金價格這一次在單日是重出了接近4%
它其實也是受到原油價格上漲
和實質利率拉昇所造成的影響
市場現在定價12月份升息一碼的幾率
大概已經來到94%
美元和美債殖利率同步走高
造成黃金價格相對大的沉壓
現在每盎司大概來到4136塊左右
上方看起來也有非常明顯的套牢賣壓區
那在種種訊息底下
我們就可以得出一些框架
可是美賽殖利率
對於各項資產都已經形成影響了
對於債市
對於黃金
對於利率型資產而言
其實都有適度的衝擊
可是現在最大的問題來自於
可是美國股市上禮拜都還在走高呢
非半創下波段新高
納指標普今年下半年都還在創高
道瓊是從防禦性資產
稍微做一些資金流出而已
對於股票市場
其實沒有造成真正足夠大的影響
那麼現在到底我們看到的
利率預期的拉伸
是否已經對於股票市場形成影響了呢
其實我個人的看法是
其實它有影響
只是從股價上看不出來
你說從股價上看不出來
那還叫影響嗎
但是從本比來看
其實是看得出來影響的
我們舉例來說
現在如果我們細看
在整個費辦的本益比預期當中
其實本益比
如果我們從費辦
現在股價是當時七八月份
股價重挫之後
開始做盤整區間
然後陸續的創下波段性高
可是如果我們仔細從相對本益比來看
當時已經從高位前瞻本益比28 29倍
一路的往下壓
好到現在大概24倍23倍22倍
到現在大概也不過接近18倍左右的位階
這說明的事情是肺瓣雖然現在位階
總體從今年來看還是偏高
在高位進行盤旋
可是從本益比來看
幾乎已經創下了五年來的新低
所以你說到底利率對於股票市場
有沒有任何的影響
我的看法是有的
只是從股價上看不出來
但是從本益比來看
其實已經看得出
目前的基期不是特別高了
那現在比較大的一個問題來自於
從上禮拜美國股市的走高
還是觀察得出內部的快速分化
我們從多項內部指標來做觀察
比如說創下52周新低的股票數量
已經連續17個交易日
超過52周新高的股票了
那代表著股票市場上漲
越來越集中在少數大型的圈子股
那標普白指數
其實也出現了差不多的現象
過去一個月站上200日均線
我們把它當成年線
成分股的比例是在快速的下滑
誒 指數還在創高
但是站上年線的成分股
反而越來越少了
那另外標普白的累積漲跌幅之間的
50日滾動相關性
在2026年又明顯的下滑
甚至一路進入到負值
這就說明著
這好像股票的創高
也就少數幾隻股票在往上衝
那如果是從平均等權指數來看
你反而很容易追不上市場的報酬
信用市場也是差不多的訊號
如果我們從過去半年標普白指數來看
它的確還在創高
可是信用評級最低的CCC的公司債
相對於BBB的公司債
信用利差還在明顯的擴大
說明高風險企業的融資壓力目前還在增加
那當然類似的股票和信用市場的概況
2000年曾經發生過
08年曾經發生過
20年還有2022年
不過這些指標它都不還算是一個標準的風險警訊
就是說它是有風險沒錯
但是它沒法證明說股市就漲到這裡了
只能說現在股市一邊上漲
但風險也在一邊的陸續提高當中
所以這個時候就變成
那麼市場就出現奇化現象
如同我們剛才所提到
現在標普大概在7700點附近
但是占上200日移動平均線的比例
本來是70%
現在只剩下52%了
只有比一半稍微多了一點點
現在是占上年限的
怎麼會標普還在創高
結果占上年限的個股
比例居然只有一半呢
這說明大多數的股票市場的強勢
並非所有股票同時間的一起參與
那美債殖利率現在又突破了5%
所以我們看到
一邊是CDS價格持續創下新高
一邊是美債殖利率創下本世紀的新高
一邊是股票市場還依舊維持在高位
打死也不願意下來
那不願意下來的根本原因是什麼呢
就是少數企業目前的獲利實在是太強大了
強大到我本益比都給你18倍了
你還想要我多低呢
我股價雖然沒有創高了
可是我獲利上升幅度很快
所以雖然看起來
我應該要反映一些利率上的預期
股市要回跌一點點
可是我告訴你
我本益比已經不高了
用這樣的一個方式
勉強撐在高位
這是大家在投資人之間
勉強形成的共識
所以我們不能說
到底債市是不是永遠
不會把股市給拖下水
也許已經拖下來了
不過拖的是本益比
拖的並非股價
那麼你到底是看股價來投資
還是你是看美國股市的基期
看是否具有價值投資點
我相信我們已經闡述目前的態度了
那當然回過頭來說
現在市場上更進一步聚焦的
就是利率預期也不太可能說
它一路走高
本益比就維持在18倍
它再更高一點
我就給你更低的本益比
也許是有道理的
畢竟現在從利率預期來看
我們主要從兩大層面來做觀察
第一大層面當然是屬於通膨的問題
這一次沙烏地阿拉伯
在橫跨東西部的關鍵油管當中
在本月份又開始遭受到顯著的無人機攻擊
那完成維修之後已經開始重新出口石油
不過呢目前運量還不敢太大
以防隨時可能遭受到攻擊
這就代表著石油風險到目前為止
還是沒有完全的解除
其實現在運量是有稍微回來一點點
整體原油的出口量已經升到
戰爭期間大概是接近三四月份左右的水準
那每日超過500萬桶
但大部分是流向亞洲
所以亞洲地區到目前為止
還是有很大程度靠補貼來撐著
現在整體雲油輸入量輸出量
正在緩步的提升當中
但是地緣政治所要求的風險一籌
還是會導致美債利率預期持續飆高
加上從下游端來看
其實壓力還是比較大的
我們從美國汽油價格
每價輪來看
現在大概是4.48美元左右
創下了歷年9月份的新高
這一次就很明顯比2025年高
比2024年高
比2023年高
甚至比2022年還要來得高了
所以當時你要知道
拜登最大的衝擊
其實就是2022年到2023年
當時的通膨危機
那麼最後導致了他的連任之路
或者賀錦麗的連任之路徹底失敗
那麼川普現在所面臨的美國汽油價格
每加侖4.48塊
大概就可以瞭解內部的壓力有多大了
我們再統計從228到整個9月27號
全球能源資產原物料價格的漲幅
其中歐洲天然氣價格漲幅
現在是變最大了
已經正式超越硫磺價格
漲幅來到129%
硫磺價格漲幅是99%
取暖油85%
柴油價格72%
汽油價格50%
布蘭特雲油45%
西德州是40%
那糧食端現在壓力也是很大的
主要就是因為硫磺和農業價格
還有一些肥料價格的上漲
稻米價格上漲60%
糖價已經漲33%
那少吃一點糖
棉花價格27%
那少吃一點棉花糖
這個不是那個棉花
玉米是20%
小麥19%
棕櫚油15%
這說明著
其實生產成本已經大幅度的擴散到
大宗資產價格當中
即便原油價格跌回來
這些有這麼好跌嗎
我們過去講過
這種成本轉嫁效果
即便價格一系列上漲以後
便當價格上漲
菜價價格下跌
肉價價格下跌
便當也不太可能回跌了
這就是目前所面臨的關卡
這也導致利率預期不斷走高之後
尤其是短天期的快速拉伸
美債值利率提現又逼近倒掛了
我們看一下兩年期和十年期的利差
一度只剩下17個基點左右
這個大概是05年初以來最小的差距
目前兩年期大概在4.9
十年期已經超過到5.2了
那更重要的事情是
目前市場反映
可能未來一年還有持續升息的空間
那短天期殖利率在往上升
兩年期殖利率就有可能再度超越十年期
最後就殖利率曲線倒掛了
那雖然過去殖利率曲線倒掛
結束好像已經不反映
資產價格一定要崩盤了
不過過去每一次倒掛
通常壓力都很大
市場會有警訊
從1960年代以來
倒掛曾經出現在最近八次的美國經濟衰退之前
從1978年來看
兩年期和十年期的曲線
平均會在衰退前15個月進入到倒掛
那這一次很明顯
不是因為真的準備要衰退了
其實更多是利率預期居高不下
一邊反映整個AI的搶錢潮
另外一邊反映通膨預期仍然屬於高位
所以這次情況就是
本來是從年初聯總會準備要降息
現在已經完全反轉成
為了要壓制通膨持續升息
如果殖利率曲線真的倒掛
代表的是再次要開始反應年總會
可能開始把利率升得太高
最終壓抑到需求和經濟成長
那銀行也可能會先受到影響
那我們先看到時候的銀行股變化
銀行股最近已經開始有所沉壓了
但也說明著川普的期待是完全落空
第一他在殖利率的控制上
對於通膨是束手無策
完全不知道該怎麼辦
這很明顯
這種原油價格
尤其是汽油價格
高得比2022年還要來得高
這一定會對於中期選舉
形成重大災難
第二件事情就是
原本在去年
大家還記得當時的鬥局
就是經濟團隊
原本是希望通過削減赤字
放鬆監管
來讓市場相信
美國財政會改善
來壓低長期利率
結果實際發展
跟原先設想是完全不同
美國目前的財政赤字
大概是佔GDP的6%
財政部長貝森特之前是333
結果現在目標3%
次之變6%
那不是兩倍嗎
所以十年金美債值的利率
也突破了2007年以來的新高
房貸利率
現在又重新佔高到接近7%
如果以40萬美元的房貸來看
每個月還款
大概又多增加了3000美元
當然了
要看一下你是浮動還是固定
不過至少還是可以看得出來
過往的預期
遭受到重大影響
美國財政部在上禮拜四
也進行了回購的美債
大概也只用了68%左右的額度
拒絕高價報價之後
殖利率又再度衝高
這次是導火線
是來自於目前擴大長天期版的美債回購
當然這一次已經比兩週前
更進一步的相對比較保守
使用率86%
更早之前曾經一度把回購額度給用滿
說明財政部現在做扭轉操作
也沒有太多那種寬鬆
或者比較力度的意願
加上最近美債又開始做標售了
大概是700億美元的五年接工債
現在都賣短債了
因為要讓市場上有接盤意願
想不到明顯低於市場預期
這一次的得標殖利率
大概是5.03%
比上一次的4.3%是大幅的跳升
代表沒有人要這些短債
形成史上第二次大的偽差
標售前的市場預期殖利率
大概是5.001%
最終還比市場預期高了3.1%
這說明投資人現在要求非常高的報酬
才願意承接這些美債
從買家結構來看
在10年前大概海外機構
比如說臺灣央行
日本央行
或者一些主權基金
投標占比大概是61%
現在只剩下54%
海外投資人幾乎沒有人想要接美債了
這個就是現在看到的實質現象
也不能說沒有要接
就是說現在美債沒那麼值錢
除非你給我更高的殖利率
5.3也不吸引我
好那要預估
那市場可能要求的是5.5
可能是6%
那美債給你10%報酬
你覺得股票市場一點影響都沒有嗎
也不可能
所以我們必須要看到
美國財政部這一次進行的美債回購
原本的目的之一
就是要改善市場的流動性
但是最終只使用68%的回購額度
原因就在於
財政部還是嚴格的遵守價格的標準
不願意為了把額度用完
而接受較低的市場報價
從程序來看
這樣做其實也沒有什麼太大問題
但是在殖利率沉壓底下
遵守機制和達成政策目的之間
有可能就存在落差
所以我們必須承認
規則如果只被機械化的來做實行
有可能就會失去規則
原本想要達成的目的
制度當然需要紀律
但是現在反而會讓人
可能遭受到一些濫用
或者說有沒有按照規則做
現在市場上
可能需要更多的利多消息
至少財政部的十足表態
才能夠緩解目前的市場壓力
要不然看起來市場上
有對於美債比較悲觀的情緒
那最後還是看
你能不能變通一些規則
既然你想要釋出一些利多
那不如勇敢多釋出一點吧
不然財政部目前的態度
看起來對於美債價格也毫無幫助
那之前網絡上的一個故事
老闆交代秘書
今天不管誰來
都跟他說我很忙
如果對方說事情很重要
你就回答每個人都這樣說的
結果下午老闆的老婆來了
秘書說不好意思
老闆今天不見任何人
老婆說我是他老婆
秘書點點頭
每個人都是這麼說的
就是政府的原本的回購美債
一開始我們知道
它是為了要改變市場的流動性
那是因為嚴格遵守價格規則
現在財政部不接受
比較差的報價
最後大量的回購額度沒有用完
市場的流動性改善也是非常有限的
殖利率反而會繼續受到沉壓
秘書完全遭老闆的交代
程序沒做錯
可是跟老闆想要達成的目的產生了落差
這就是我們目前面臨的挑戰
當然了
如果我們從川普目前在支持律所面臨的壓力
其實真正大的壓力
美債殖利率是一個
但是隻是大家要求更高的風險貼水
也不是完全沒有人要
真正最大的壓力
還是來自於川普本身
剛才我們聊到的
美債市場價格的拋售壓力
搭配著汽油價格的創高
那再知道
這一次民調層面
不管是華爾街日報
左媒右媒
陸續所公佈的民調
幾乎都在快速的向下
如果我們細節觀察
在整個9月份所進行的民調
川普目前的工作支持率
大概是37%
這個是1990年以來
總統在期中選舉前
同期相對中低的水準
從歷史數據來顯示
拜登在2022年
當時通膨很嚴重
43%
還比現在川普高
川普第一任任期
2018年有44%
也比現在來得高
歐巴馬在10年和14年
分別有46和40%
小布希有64%
06年39%
科林頓1994年是48%
98年是66%
老布希1990年更是達到75%
這說明任何總統在其中選舉的民調
都遠遠比川普目前在工作支持率
還要高非常多
如果細看
六成選民主要還是認為
在經濟政策上讓美國變得更差了
只有33%的受訪者認為
美國的經濟狀況良好
65%是給予相對負面的評價
所以一切我個人的看法是
都是圍繞著通膨
從選舉角度來看
也不能說完全沒有救
就現在選前倒數兩個月了
應該想倒數一個月了
美國家庭對於財富和購買力的感受
能不能快速的改善
現在民調38%到39%
第一點大概33%
民主黨在國會的一般選票
大概是以53%對上41%領先共和黨
更為關鍵的是
34%的選民認為自己的家庭
在財務比前一年還來得更加惡化
所以這個時候理論上
一部分的選民會因為經濟體感
快速的倒向民主黨
但目前還沒有足夠的證據可以下結論
因為美國現在經濟就很尷尬
體感上是很差沒錯
可是AI正在大爆發
就跟臺灣
臺灣當然有些人覺得
這個所得的差距
K型崩壞壓力很大
但臺灣GDP成長11%
你能夠說經濟差嗎
所以我認為美國的問題
目前並不是典型的經濟蕭條
它是affordable
就是我們講說
這個市場的可負擔能力
這樣子的一個變化
就業和消費還是有韌性
但是房貸接近7%
然後食物和食品價格
還是處於高檔
大家就是過得
購買力慢慢被侵蝕
所以這個值得注意的地方
就是富裕社會的窮
跟真正我們缺乏
基本生存物資的窮
它是不同的事情
美國人現在的不滿
也不是沒有飯吃
就是以前一份薪水
可以負擔的房子
汽車 醫療 食物和休閒
今天需要付出更高的收入
才能夠維持
那也不是沒有錢
但是就是要壓縮一些
我的平時的休閒娛樂消費
所以這才是我們觀察到的
實質現象
以前常常講說
美國人也有幾千萬人吃不飽
還要領糧食券
可是你要想想看
我們講的吃不飽
跟會餓死
它還是有區別的
你爺爺說
說他沒有衣服穿
跟你老婆說他沒有衣服穿
那不同回事
一個是那個年代物資匱乏
沒有衣服穿
一個是他就過得比較辛苦一點點
所以不管怎麼說
我們現在觀察到的設置跡象就是
還有兩個月的時間
可以快速的讓通膨下壓
有點壓力
可是至少讓能源資產價格先下跌
第二
股票市場繼續的上漲
財富效應還能夠維持
目前的消費繁榮
就是雖然購買力被侵衰了一點點
可是至少我在財富效應上的擴張
幻覺可以讓我勇敢的去定
下一次廉價的機票
這個就很重要了
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
也許民調預期感沒有想象中來的差
如果每次都根據民調來看
那川普也不會贏得總統大選
但至少可以看得出來
他是受到懲押的
好那這時候回過頭來看
美債殖利率的狂飆
到底美國股市會怎麼走呢
我個人的看法是
也許沒有想象中這麼悲觀
我們從過去幾次的經驗來做一些推論
94年是美債市場價格最經典的一次債券大屠殺
當時是2月份的聯準會意外升息
由於市場原先認為通膨還是溫和
幾乎沒有做到準備
所以短短40個交易日
10年級美債值的利率直接上升超過一個百分點
那標普白指數下跌了大概8%
後來市場發現
市場沒有因為升息而進入到衰退
企業獲利還受到經濟和景氣的強行支撐
所以美國股市最後收復了跌幅
這是94年的經驗
再來看一下99年
99年情況不太一樣
這是債券市場比聯準會更早反應
因為新一輪的預防性升息
開始前的幾個月
新年期美債殖利率就已經上升了一個百分點
美國股市就震盪了幾個月份
然後到2000年網絡泡沫破滅之後
再開始重挫
不過在當時泡沫破滅之前
目前市場資金對於科技股相對而言
買盤就已經開始有所減弱了
所以它其實並不是因為利率升高
泡沫撲滅
它其實更多的就是
網路本身就是一場泡沫
太多虛假的公司
再看一下06年
06年當時是國際油價大漲
推升了通膨
沒在此利率跟著升
連總會也跟著升息
不過美國股市還是保持有相當大的韌性
它是一直等到07年
次貸海嘯爆發之後才開始往下崩
至少從短期半年內走勢來看
看不出美國股市有遭受到利率預期升息
所導致的美國股市的重挫
再來就是16年
16年的部分
這個大家稍微有點感受到了
美債值利率和美國股市
它是同步走深的
就是來自於因為市場認為經濟終於正常化
脫離了08年以來的貨幣寬鬆
再來一次最慘烈的就是2022年
這個就記憶有聲了
2022年比較標準的就是
當時是暴利升息
因為烏二戰時的影響
全球供給鏈大斷
通膨大幅拉昇
最後估值的削減
不過在兩年之後
美國股市又創下歷史新高了
好那現在回到2026年
美債殖利率升到了
接近20年來的高點
聯準會議也已經升息一次
但是美國經濟
還是維持相當大的韌性
其中一個重要的支撐
就是來自於什麼
因為AI正在爆發
所以我們要講的事情就是
並不是美債殖利率的上升
對於股市沒影響
而是它的影響是反映在本益比
那隻要獲利上升的速度過快
即便本益比很低
它搞不好股價也在創高
這是第一個角度
那第二件事情就是
所以美債殖利率
完全對於股市沒有影響嗎
不會
有一天美債
你躺著
它也給你10%報酬
肯定有影響的
可是問題在於
如果我們對於AI的幻想更高
那就是以前五年前
美債殖利率給你5%
那是遙不可及的夢了
因為那是無風險利率
可我現在告訴你
AI一年是給你這樣20% 30%
一樣大家把錢質押
還是買去買股票
這個就是形成市場的預期落差
所以從頭到尾
為什麼美債殖利率現在這麼高
但是美國股市還沒有崩呢
因為從頭到尾
都是市場對於AI的信心
一方面是對於未來的信心
第二方面
就算有估值削減
它也反映在基期和本益比身上了
好 我們看一下
美國股市四大指數表現
道瓊指數下跌347點
0.67%
是在51481點
標普下跌59點
0.77%
刷7,683點
納指下跌248點
0.92%
刷26,820點
其實三大指數
上禮拜都還在創高之後
稍微做一些拉回而已
也沒有跌這麼重
倍半下跌203.1.6%
刷12,465點
看起來是有一點底部逐步形成
事實上
輝達雖然還沒有來到歷史新高
不過從形態上來看
下方的量價買盤
還是比較踴躍一點的
也沒那麼容易跌破
甚至如果我們從上方價格來看
一片晴朗
要突破也不是這麼難的事情
不過這也如同我們過去所講的
由於現在美國股市
是集中到少部分個股當中
所以即便指數在創高
可能體感上還是沒有這麼的明顯
加上這一次川習會之後
我們不看美國股市的反應
我們先看中國股市
這次在川習會
原本預估美中關係
可以稍微緊張局勢稍微降溫
不過中國股市在中秋節
首個交易日明顯重挫
說明市場上
也沒有看到太多的利多消息
滬深300指數是收跌了2.2%
這是創下五週以來的
最大單日跌幅
已經碰到2025年8月份以來的
最低水準了
上證指數也下跌了1.7%
所以你說川習會有多大的
美中全面和諜的期待嗎
其實也沒有
大家就稍微談幾點共識
如果細節觀察
在共識層面
好消息是臺灣議題
至少沒有納入到共識決當中
可能私底下談
但是在雙邊關係上
雙方同意互相支持對方
辦好聚團體和亞太金河會
金河會峰會
針對伊朗局勢打成了目前相對大的共識
伊朗不得發展核武器
不過雙方是否代表著
在伊朗局勢會推進速度
看起來也無法
經貿層面
中國又承諾了
會採購300億美元的美國農產品
現在美方會啟動中美貿易委員會
和美中投資委員會
雙方可能也會針對
另外300億美元的關稅採取優惠
關於反毒層面
中美會聯合偵破
更多的新興毒品的案件
中方也會根據美方的資訊
來追查涉嫌製毒
銷往北美的中國公民
另外一個就是AI
AI雙方已經建立好對等對話
美方會以超級智慧
就是超級AI來取代AI的說法
下一次的交流預估在11月左右來做舉行
整體共識就是
有一些好消息
也沒什麼太大的壞消息
不過基本都符合預期之中
現在要了解
即便雙方互相降了600億美元的商品關稅
可是其實佔雙邊的貿易還是很小一部分
大部分都是來自於一些小部分的玩具
或者我們看到廚房用品
潔淨的裝飾
中國涵蓋美國的肉類海鮮爐製品
也能夠降到一些關稅
所以雙方的關稅戰
目前還在緩步的熄火當中
可是我們也清楚知道
美方大概也理解到
關稅戰打擾半天
基本上只針對高科技產品有效
大多數產品
其實並沒有產生多大的效力
中國現在大概一個產品
普遍現在大概認為有40種渠道
用不同的國家出口到美國
那美方當然認為
中國商品目前直接進入到美國
平均關稅大概是50%
只要經歷過低關稅國家
就能夠成功的壓低一些實際稅負
大概可以少至少一半左右
那美方在這個層面
看起來也無意監管
做更進一步的一個課程
主要就還是來自於
美中雙方現在倒有一個合理的理由
有來降溫
中國內需還是比較疲憊一點的
美方需要在期中選舉之前
儘可能的讓通膨預期
能夠快速的下滑
加上我們也知道
9月份本來要出來的301條款
現在9月底了還沒有出來
可是IEPA幾乎已經全面取消
目前IEPA的關稅
預估在今年下半年
會進行大規模的退稅
這是最高法院的指令
本來這個是美國關稅
已經是美國政府
非常重要的收入來源了
那現在看起來
這一批稅收要大量的償還
可能對於美國的財政壓力
又會形成進一步的拉伸
這是我們觀察到的失之現象
但我們還是可以很清楚知道
川普現在能夠做的
基本上就是壓低能源價格
還有拉抬財富效果
股票市場
關稅戰本身到底
對於川普在過去兩年任期
是不是一個加分的作用
很難說
因為美國提高關稅
原本是希望
可以保護本國產業
促進製造業迴流
但實際效果的看法是
它的確增加了投資的增長
但是並沒有因為關稅
而讓美國的財政體制還要來得更好
所以主要還是集中在
投資成果的另外一部分
所以我們必須承認
對於其他國家而言
那個傷害就真的比較大一點
我們看幾個國家目前的平均關稅稅率
臺灣市場的部分到目前為止
整體而言大概還是6.9%
其實並沒有想象中來得高
其他國家
比如說我們看到在歐元區9.8%
那日本大概13.5%
南韓大概13.1%
從這件事情都看得出來
大家的關稅還是比以前高了一個臺階
那大家的出口還是在創高
可是對於真實傳產而言
大部分其實還是可以看得出來
遭受到極大的市場壓力
這也說明著美國提高關稅
原本是希望能夠保護本國產業
那製造業能夠迴流
這倒也是沒有迴流
不過AI本地的投資設廠
造成了名目上數據還是非常漂亮
但是你的選擇
對於其他國家的傳產
還是造成了一定程度的影響
產生了一些外部成本
而且成本很大程度
也不是由做決定的人來承擔
對於國家來說是如此
對於一個政府來說
他為了保護產業
增加財政收入
或者追求國家的安全
提高關稅
的確最後繞了一大圈
還是回到國內要承擔相對性的物價
這也給投資聘用做些觀察
就簡單來講就是
你的選擇一定會產生適度的外部效應
那成本不一定是由做決定的人承擔
那反而大家都承擔更多了
那整個經濟體制
只是靠AI的繁榮
去撐住這一場關稅戰的混亂而已
我前兩天才看到一條新聞
講的是臺大南一
驚傳有人接連四天在淋浴間大便
引發了全體住宿的怒吼
我還稍微看了一下影片
因為為了要逮捕這個嫌犯
學生是不惜半夜埋伏
最後找到這位秦始皇
據說這位秦始皇是醫學系的菜鳥
遭到逮捕之後
他也承認當天的確是他拉的
但是其他三天是跟自己無關的
當天是在忍不住
確實讓我看到臺大學生的行動力
對臺大醫學院
未來的醫生到處拉屎
還幫你看醫生
所以不管怎麼說
我要講的事情就是
這件事情本質上都是
你的選擇一定會產生極大的外部成果
這個成本
它不一定是由做決定的人承擔
一個人覺得在公共浴室做
一個覺得自己有趣的事情
最後有可能要室友承擔
社間承擔
整間宿舍為他而承擔
好噁心
我就覺得好噁心
所以決定晚一點講
不過時間差不多
叫死皇帝
對
南一好像從很久以前
就經常有人在拉屎了
這它是一個傳統
就是好像一個人走之後
總會有另外一個人跟著拉
沒事
這不叫死瑞克
也叫秦始皇
也叫死瑞克
沒事
好噁心
我們今天主要跟投資朋友
稍微梳理一下秦始皇
不是稍微梳理一下
今天我們看到美債殖利率的快速飆升
搭配著目前在能源資產價格的走高
川習會雖然帶來了部分關稅鬆綁
或者美中關係稍微降溫的訊號
但是利多很快就退燒了
現在是油價的走高
怎麼壓下來
通膨的一律問題
市場重新壓住
聯儲會會升息
讓十年期美債殖利率持續拉昇
所以對於股票市場而言
有沒有影響
其實影響是蠻大的
估值正在快速的遞減
那股價不一定有影響
可是本益比的下滑就足以彰顯著
當利率預期越高
我們好像就無法給它更高的估值了
股價本來要漲五成的
現在只能漲兩成
所以不要看股價沒有下跌而覺得氣餒
重點是AI其實已經開始爆發了
那美債殖利率也開始壓抑了
目前美股的估值
這是目前呈現最好的答案
那至於美國股市在估值低的時候
該做什麼事情呢
這就是目前我們給予市場的態度了
給投資朋友做一些參考
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上半半
早晨財經速解讀再相見
祝各位投資朋友
開門順利
操辦愉快